over the past few decades bonds have
fallen out of favor the average person
isn't even aware what exactly bonds are
while investors avoid them like the
plague
this is quite ironic given that the
biggest companies in the world often do
the exact opposite holding tens of
billions if not hundreds of billions in
bonds for example we often hear that
apple has nearly 200 billion dollars in
cash but this is rather misleading
because they don't actually hold
anywhere near this amount in cash
apple actually only holds 28 billion
dollars in cash
the rest of apple's money is held in
what are called marketable securities
which are basically just bonds and other
fixed income assets
apple currently holds 23 billion
short-term marketable securities and 141
billion dollars in long-term marketable
securities in fact a few years ago apple
was the 23rd largest us treasury
investor in the world beating out most
countries and if you take a look at the
other leading companies in the world
you'll find a very similar story google
for instance is currently holding 113
billion dollars in marketable securities
so here's why these companies hold the
vast majority of their cash in
marketable securities and why all
americans should be investing in bonds
as well
before we jump into why bonds could be a
favorable investment let's first recap
what exactly bonds even are in the first
place bonds are basically iou statements
handed out by governments and
corporations around the world whenever
these entities need money to build a
road or a new factory they'll issue
these iou statements and they'll promise
to pay a certain amount of interest
until they pay back the full amount so
you as a bondholder are basically a
loaning agency to these massive entities
usually the vast majority of bonds are
sold to institutions like pension funds
and other countries like china but this
isn't on purpose
in fact governments around the world
would prefer to issue their bonds to
their citizens this way they're paying
interest to their citizens instead of
china or russia most governments
actually go out of their way to ensure
that their bonds are easily accessible
to the average person the us government
for example guarantees that they'll
offer you at least 5 million worth of
each bond every single time they issue
bonds
in other words you don't have to compete
with the big institutions and countries
unless you're buying more than 5 million
worth of treasury bonds on a regular
basis it's not just the federal
governments that are issuing bonds
either
usually most areas will issue their own
bonds to fund a local dam or highway
these are called municipal bonds and
they're a great way to earn money while
supporting your local communities also
interest payments earned from municipal
bonds are exempt from federal income
taxes and sometimes also state and local
taxes as well and if you live in a high
tax area this could make the interest
earned from these bonds far more
valuable for example if you're taxed
forty percent a municipal bond that pays
back three percent would actually be
equivalent to a regular investment
paying back five percent anyway moving
on to corporate bonds this is where
you'll find the most amount of
competition because companies generally
offer the highest interest rates and
they issue a limited number of bonds but
if you stick with large corporations
like apple who regularly issue billions
of dollars worth of bonds it shouldn't
be too hard to get your hands on these
either
alright now that we've discussed the
basic premise of bonds let's take a look
at why they're worth owning by far the
biggest advantage of bonds and
especially u.s treasury bonds is their
safety in fact treasury bonds are so
safe that the interest earned from these
bonds are considered risk-free i mean
this shouldn't be that surprising given
that a country like the us has virtually
no risk of default because they can just
print money to pay back their bond
holders this means that you're basically
guaranteed to make money if you simply
hold to maturity and this is why
marketable securities are generally just
considered cash
now if you try to exit your investment
early you may be looking at a loss
depending on how the bond market is
doing at a given time but if you hold to
a maturity it's basically like earning
interest from a savings account which is
unfortunately non-existent nowadays
corporate bonds on the other hand are by
no means risk-free but one positive is
that the risk is always clearly defined
you can look at a company's annual
earnings their profit margins and their
balance sheet to get a pretty good idea
of how likely they are to pay back their
debt and if you don't want to do that
you can take a look at risk ratings from
reputable companies like snp or moody's
usually these ratings separate corporate
bonds into two sections which are
investment grade bonds and
non-investment grade bonds for our
purposes we're mainly going to focus on
investment grade bonds these ratings are
super stringent and aaa ratings are
basically never handed out in fact
there's only three corporations in the
entire world that have a aaa rating
which are apple microsoft and johnson
johnson also it should be noted that
apple didn't even join this list till
the end of last year something else to
note is that if these companies do
collapse for some reason you're one of
the first people who are paid out after
liquidation according to section 507 of
the bankruptcy code the first people who
are paid out are secured debt holders
who have collateral but after these guys
are paid out bond holders are next in
line meanwhile shareholders are last in
line and they're usually not paid very
much if anything so if you're looking
for safety stability and security bonds
are definitely the way to go
one of the biggest criticisms against
bonds is that their yields are not that
high nowadays but i don't exactly think
that this is a bad thing sure bond
yields will never be as high as stock
returns but that's because you're taking
on substantially more risk and
volatility by investing in stocks all
assets are directly correlated to risk
they carry so it's not fair to say that
bonds as a whole are not worth it simply
because they offer lower returns than
stocks not to mention it there's plenty
of bonds that offer great yields if you
do your research likely the most
underrated bond in the entire world is
i-series bonds i-series bonds are
inflation-protected bonds that are
issued by the u.s government and they're
specifically designed to ensure that you
make a return even after accounting for
inflation and the given that inflation
is kai high right now so are yields on
eye bonds right now i bonds are paying
out a whopping 9.62 percent and you have
up until october to buy these interest
rates
if you didn't notice that's literally
higher than the average return on the s
p 500 now of course if inflation goes
down so will the returns on i bonds but
you'll never be losing money to
inflation in other words this is a
perfect store of value that's backed by
the us government the only catch is that
you can only buy ten thousand dollars
worth of i bonds every calendar year but
for the average person if you're also
maxing out your 401k and roth ira every
year and building up a larger emergency
fund like any responsible person should
do it this limit is likely more than
enough also if you do want to buy more
bonds there's plenty of solid options if
you do some digging take this oracle
bond for instance this bond matures in
may of 2025 and at current prices you
can lock in a yield over four percent
and that's just for holding three years
if you're willing to lock in for a
longer period like 20 years you can buy
the 2039 oracle bond that currently
offers a 5.79 yield some other high
yielding investment grade issuers
including mcdonald's atnt boeing and
fedex so clearly if you look deep enough
you can still find bonds that yield over
five percent
one of the biggest shortfalls of most
arguments against bonds is that they
almost always compare bonds to stocks or
real estate but the flaw with this
argument is that bonds don't have to be
treated as replacement to stock or real
to investing rather they could be
treated as a replacement to cash
after all basically every major
corporation out there holds the vast
majority of their cash in marketable
securities also regardless of how low
bond yields go they will always be
higher than the yields offered in
savings accounts now i'm not suggesting
that people hoard cash just so they can
invest in bonds the number one thing
that the average person should be doing
with access savings is investing in the
s p 500 however this doesn't mean that
there's no room for bonds there's plenty
of use cases in which bonds make a lot
more sense than cash
one example is saving up for a house
right now the median price of a house in
the us is 428 thousand dollars let's say
this is your first house and you're
looking to buy right underneath the
median at four hundred thousand dollars
to come up with a 20 down payment you
would need 80 000
there's also closing costs moving costs
and new furniture expenses so let's say
you budget out 100 000 for this new
house and to achieve this you're looking
to save 20 000 per year for five years
if you were to simply leave this money
in a savings account you might be able
to earn half a percent interest per year
at this rate you would earn about 1200
in interest by the time you buy the
house now what if you invested in boeing
bonds instead
boeing obviously isn't going anywhere in
the next five years and you can earn
about a five percent deal with this
boeing may 297 bond this yield will
slowly fall with time as we get closer
to maturity so while you may be locking
in a five percent deal during your first
12 months of saving you'll probably only
be locking in at one percent yield
during your last one months of saving to
keep things simple let's just say that
you average a three percent yield
throughout the next five years
at this rate you would earn seven
thousand six hundred dollars by the time
you're ready to buy your house that
itself could be enough to pay for your
closing costs and this logic doesn't
just apply to saving for a house either
it makes sense whenever you need money
on a set date or whenever you have
access cash reserves maybe you have
fifty thousand dollars set aside for a
car but you're waiting for the next
month to release in six or twelve months
putting this money in reliable bonds
would be way better than just holding
cash
clearly while bonds may not be a great
substitute for stocks or real estate
they can be a phenomenal substitute for
cash
despite all these benefits many people
including even warren buffett claim that
bonds aren't that useful in the current
market environment but the thing to note
about virtually everyone who claims this
is that they're not comparable to the
average person warren buffett has
averaged 20.5 percent per year from his
stock investments since 1965
so he's obviously not going to be
thrilled about a bond that's paying 5
per year but for the average person who
isn't a stock market genius and may not
even have any investments at all bonds
could be a great alternative to just
having all of their money in a savings
account also bonds could be a great
introduction to investing in general the
everyday person is usually intimidated
by the stock market because earning
reports and balance sheets seem complex
and hard to understand but bonds are
extremely straightforward you loan money
to the government or the most reputable
companies in the world and they pay you
back with interest by a certain date as
long as you hold to maturity you don't
have to worry about volatility or
fluctuating interest rates or any of
that and starting to earn money through
bonds may be exactly what the average
person needs to make the plunge into
stocks and take investing as a whole
more seriously and that's why i think
all americans should be investing in
bonds but that's just what i think would
you guys invest in bonds comment that
down below
also drop a like if you think eye bonds
are underrated and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider the
subscribe and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one